alors avec vous d'un mini verdeilhan
revenons sur cette affaire patrick dils
pendant quinze ans on s'est basé sur les
aveux de l'accusé alors que la justice
française on le sait officiellement est
basé sur la preuve est la preuve et
l'épreuve il n'y en avait pas oui tout à
fait les aveux six fois réitérés de
patrick 10 en quelques jours et est le
seul élément à charge vous l'avez dit il
n'y avait aucune preuve il n'y avait
aucun indice aucun témoin aucune
empreinte pour soutenir l'accusation
les pièces à conviction qui sont en
général devant les jurés au fil des
audiences avait été détruite en toute
légalité en 1995 deal c'était donc j'ai
à dire son propre accusateur des aveux
crédible et un accusé qui dans le box
étaient difficilement convaincant des
aveux qui par deux fois ont emporté la
conviction des jurés à metz et à reims
avec une inconnue quand même à lyon
s'agit-il d'un verdict d'innocents ch ou
bien le résultat d'un doute qu'ils
avaient été soutenus vous en souvenez il
ya deux jours par l'avocat général alors
on a entendu à l'instant même roland
agret parlé de réparations comment
peut-on réparer s'il s'agit d'une erreur
judiciaire oui peut-on indemniser
peut-on réparer 15 ans la moitié d'une
vie pour patrick dils alors ses avocats
vont se tourner devant la commission
d'indemnisation de la détention
provisoire il demande la somme de 2
millions 300 euros c'est à dire à peu
près 15 millions de francs le record
pour l'instant s'élève à un million et
demi qui a été donnée un ancien
administrateur judiciaire de nanterre
pour six mois de détention provisoire à
l'opposé rida balouche qui a été
acquitté après un procès en révision
indemnités zéro franc les magistrats ont
estimé je cite l'erreur judiciable est
imputable à l'intéressé c'est un
précédent fâcheux pour batteries disent
merci dominique